[Music]
you do some tweets that seem to be
conspiracy theories some of these
conspiracy theories uh have turned out
to be true Hunter Biden laptop Twitter
and others engage in active suppression
of information that was relevant to the
public you tweeted this thing about
George Soros you said wants to erode the
very fabric of civilization and Sor
hates Humanity do you think I think
that's true that's my opinion but why
share it freedom of speech I'm allowed
to say what I want you absolutely are
but I'm trying to understand why you do
because you have to know it's got a the
partisan divide in the country it makes
you a lightning rod for criticism seen
in the princess Bri he confronts the
person who killed his father and he says
offer me money offer me power I don't
care I'll say what I want to say and if
the consequence of that is losing money
so
be
how you doing people I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report it's November 30th
2023 can you guys believe tomorrow is
December it is December sweet Jesus this
year went by fast we are live streaming
on rumble on locals and on YouTube Share
subscribe tap that notification Bell if
you have not and as always there is a
postgame show where you can ask me
questions you can offer up your own
thoughts you can correct me you can
needle and poke me whatever you'd like
to do at Ruben report. locals.com and
our cold open today of Elon Musk you may
remember that clip uh from a couple
months back uh but that really is going
to set us up for today's show we're
doing a a community Q&A but I want to
sort of open up with a couple stories
related to Elon because he was uh doing
a live CNBC event yesterday at with this
guy Andrew sorin and he just absolutely
Unleashed I think the the inner tiger of
this guy has fully come out uh you know
he's very softspoken for the most part
I've spent a little time with him he's
thoughtful he's kind of he's kind of
soft I think he sort of runs cool
actually maybe not in his his business
decisions but I think his temperament as
a human being is kind of cool but in
light of everything that has happened
with him in the last year and a half
where before that he was a darling of
the left and he was helping with green
energy and Electric cars and he was a
good liberal and all of those things and
how they have subsequently treated him
in this last year and a half since he
got X started allowing for more free
speech and of course in the last two
weeks is suddenly being called the
number one anti-semite in the world
while you know the lefties celebrate
Hamas I think he has just about had it
so let's just dive into clip number one
so here he is at this CNBC event uh and
he's asked about uh what he's going to
do about the advertisers who are now
trying to Blackmail X basically all of
these companies that are saying hey if
you allow anti-Semitism if you allow
hate and
racism on the Twitter well what will you
do obviously you know that there's a
public perception that and and you're
clarifying this
now um but there's a public perception
that that was part of a apology tour if
you will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers we talked to Bob I hope they
stop you hope uh don't advertise you
don't want them to advertise no what do
you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob you're in the
audience you know what funny you know
how on this show occasionally I do drop
the f bomb and I try to control it and
sometimes I can't sometimes Connor's
fingers a little bit like this because
he's trying to bleep things that's what
they've pushed him to does that strike
you as the Elon Musk that we all know
that I've shown you a zillion clips of
of calmly explaining things talking
about his belief in free speech talking
about why he thinks that I don't know
say getting information out to people is
an important thing etc etc they pushed
him into this also the way that Andrew
sorin asked the question people are
saying the public perception is this no
one in their right mind thinks or ever
thought that Elon Musk is an anti-semite
these people find racism everywhere
except where it actually is uh we were
able to come up with a alternative view
of the exact same clip this is going to
blow your mind watch this one there's a
public perception that that was part of
a apology tour there was advertisers
leaving we talked to Bob I hope they
stop you don't want them to advertise no
if somebody's going to try to Blackmail
me with advertising blackmail me with
money go
yourself
a
[Applause]
go there's the internet for you I have
no doubt that some people at Media
Matters are watching this right now
going Dave Ruben sharing misinformation
somebody
um Elon continued because you know he
bought this thing for
$44 billion a company that certainly was
not worth that and well not only was it
not worth that it's been purging money
it was purging money before him and it's
been purging less money we think since
him and he also fired half the company
and everything else but it unfortunately
is on the road to bankruptcy because you
can only Purge money for so long even
when the richest man in the world owns
you uh so he was asked about that well
let me ask you
then that's how I feel don't
advertise how do you think then about
the economics of of x if if if if part
of the underlying model at least today
and maybe it needs to shift maybe the
answer is it needs to shift away from
advertising um if if you believe that
this is the one part of your business
where you will be beholden to those who
uh have this
view what do you do uh
why I I I understand but there's a
reality
too
right yes no no Lind Yaro is right here
and she's got to sell advertis
absolutely so um no no tell me so so
what no no actually what what this
advertising boycott is uh is is going to
do it's going to kill the
company and do you think that but and
the whole world will know that those
those advertisers killed the company and
we will document it in great
detail but there are those advertisers I
imagine are going to say they're going
to say we can kill the company oh yeah
they're going to say tell it to tell to
Earth but they're going to say that
they're going to say Elon that you
killed the company because you said
these things and that they were
inappropriate things and they didn't
feel comfortable on the platform right
that's that's what they're going to say
and let's see how Earth responds to
that that that is so good it is so right
first you know I also want to note I I
talked about temperament and he runs
kind of cool you know even the way Elon
speaks he he kind of stammers a little
bit and you can see that he's thinking
things through and almost as if his
brain is working a little faster than
his mouth so when they push him to the
fu when they push him to that you have
to understand something has shifted with
him I am telling you what mark my words
that clip what you just saw right there
I think he just drew his Line in the
Sand period he just said basically you
you can't you can't buy me out right you
can't threaten me with money so if
ultimately this company fails because
even I can't lose hundreds of millions
or billions of dollars a year everyone
will know tell it to Earth ERS did this
and you know there's a certain irony I
don't know much about this Andrew sorin
guy but you know he works I guess for
the New York Times or at least in
partnership with the New York Times and
CNBC because that's what was behind his
head over there the New York Times lies
about everything the New York Times has
shared far more actual anti-semitic
conspiracy theories and pushed more BLM
BS and lied about vaccines and
everything that the New York Times does
but that guy is the tarity to sit there
and and make it seem like Elon Musk is
the bigot which is a perfect segue to
our next segment because uh then he
asked Elon or Elon just sort of
pontificated on something that I think
we all see it's the fake good guys right
it's the virtue signalers who pretend
they are good while doing all of the
wrong things Tesla currently sells two
twice as much uh in terms of electric
vehicles as the rest of electric car
makers in United States combined Tesla
has done more to help the environment
than uh all other companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done more for the environment than
everyone any single human on earth how
do you feel about
that how I feel about that yeah no I'm
I'm asking you personally how you feel
about that because this goes we're
talking about power and influence and
I'm saying I'm saying what what I care
about is the the reality of goodness not
the perception of it and what I see all
over the place is people who care about
looking good while doing
evil
them okay do you see how they could push
a good man into starting to seem like
he's the crazy guy now I don't think
he's the crazy guy I don't think you
think he's the crazy guy but you can see
it right here he is saying hey I've done
more for the environment he's not saying
it to Pat himself on the back what a
great line I believe in the reality of
goodness not the perception of goodness
that's what virtue signaling is Right
everyone virtue signals about how
wonderful they are and all the things
that they do and everyone else is bad
and they're so good here's a guy
actually doing good he has done good
with Tesla I can tell you this you know
we have two Teslas okay we have two
Teslas and even if Tesla was doing jack
for the environment the cars are
awesome everyone that gets in my car
that's never been in a Tesla is like
this is the coolest freaking thing ever
they drive beautifully they're the
safest car on the road everything else
putting aside any of the environmental
stuff you'd also like to make a buck
while doing some good for the world and
not only is he doing good for this world
he is literally trying to get it so that
there will be interplanetary life which
ultimately we will need because this
planet is most likely going to burn
right like that is sort of where it's
all heading and by the way it's not
going to burn because of climate change
it's going to be burning because of all
the lunatics who are gladly setting a
blaze all of the the goodness that
humans have worked on over thousands and
thousands of years so the reality of
goodness over the perception of goodness
dare I say there's a little bit this is
going to sound like really lofty lofty
but there's a little bit of like a Jesus
quality there right like there really is
he's trying to do good and what is the
system doing to him right Christmas is
coming that is kind of the story of
Jesus right here a good person in a bad
time is suddenly thought of as the bad
guy and actually I'm on it with the
Segways today that's a perfect segue
because uh last night speaking of bad
people virtue signaling so they do not
do good things they pretend to do good
things but they're usually doing evil
things unlike Elon Musk uh there was a
quote flood the tree lighting for Gaza
protest SL rot outside of Fox News
headquarters and the Christmas tree in
Rockefeller Center the famous Christmas
tree that is beloved by New Yorkers of
all religions and stripes and walks of
life I used to go there growing up we
would take trips into into New York City
to see the Christmas tree uh here's some
video of the protest at the tree last
night
[Music]
all right let's not even bother with Fox
News here Fox News happens to be there
this was about the tree they called it
flood the tree lighting so it's you know
as somebody has said on Twitter it's now
getting uh quoted all over the place I
don't know who came up with the line
originally maybe we can find it is they
come for the Saturday people first and
then they go for the Sunday people and
that's what's happening here I've said
it all along if you think this ends with
the Jews they are they are imagine if
this was any other situation right
imagine if this was during Ramadan and a
bunch of Christ masked Christians and
Jews with crazy signs and everything
else were protesting at a mosque right
how would the reaction be but I'm seeing
a lot of quietness from people who would
usually be outraged because people don't
know what to do about this and by the
way it was a riot it was not peaceful
and yes there were calls for genocide
and there were swastikas out there and
more uh here's just a little bit of one
of the brawls with the New York police
officers who by the way although many of
them um they don't they seemingly don't
do their job I have a lot of sympathy
for whoever is left and it's an
unwinable untenable situation because
they have a horrible mayor and they are
being told to stand down all the time so
occasionally they get into situations
like
[Music]
[Applause]
this
[Music]
I have simply no doubt that guy that was
res resisting arrests or fighting with
the cops is not in jail right now like
there's just no I have no evidence we
checked this morning that anyone got
arrested there now I want to just show
you one more because if you think that
they are not brazenly abusing whatever
laws I mean they're not even laws
anymore if no one if no one behaves like
they're laws then they're not laws in
these blue uh these blue cities um but I
want to show you one more check check
this one out tell me if this behavior is
legal I I'm not a legal expert maybe we
can get someone on the line but tell me
if this seems like you know this should
be allowed in a in a functioning Society
you want what do you want what do you
want I can't hear you what do you want
[Applause]
that is a police officer's hat a member
of the NYPD once the most respected
Police Department quite literally in the
world that was stolen from him may maybe
it fell off but in essence stolen might
have fallen off in a melee but stolen
from him lit on fire uh and then a guy
Dr like a cobra Soldier and Cobra were
the bad guys in gi. Joe uh then brought
it out to the middle of the street and
dropped it there and then of course all
the you know the mob of reporters and
reporters I don't know what they are
these people that just come around and
film everything so there's several laws
that were broken there nobody will do
anything about it and I tweeted it out
right before the show this is a good
litmus test for New York City and for
Eric Adams and the New York Police
Department someone can identify that guy
if you cannot at least arrest that guy
then I I truly mean this with with no
sarcasm or hyperbole or anything else
then if you are a sane person you must
leave New York City now no one is coming
to help you and I know and I know this
is true they're they're not going to
arrest this guy you must leave New York
City now there is no store that they
will not ransack there is
no there is no church nor nor Christmas
tree that they will not desecrate forget
the temples and everything else or
Jewish owned shops that's all obvious uh
it's all on it's all on and remember
those are the people that are pretending
to be the good guys so now I want to
jump back to Elon Musk for a second
because when he's talking about the
virtue signalers the people uh who want
to perceive themselves to be good rather
than the reality of actually being good
one of the things that the left has done
over the last couple years uh is made it
seem like it's always the people on the
right that are coming after your Free
Speech but if we've learned anything
it's that the left and the wers and all
of big tech people those are the ones
the Democrats the lefties who are
actually coming for your free speech
take a look the Democrats appear to be
more Pro censorship than the Republicans
I me that used to be the opposite it
used to be you know left position was
freedom of speech um you know uh I
believe one point um the ACLU even def
defended the right of someone to claim
that they were Nazi or something like
that you know so like there were there
really were uh like the left was freedom
of speech is is is fundamental um and I
mean my at least perception Perhaps it
is inaccurate is that um the pro
sensorship is more on the left than than
the right I really can't get over this
thing about the way he speaks and how
he's giving the other side every benefit
of the to my perception maybe it's not
correct no your perception is correct
and actually the first time that I met
with Elon at Twitter in San Francisco we
talked about a few things about my
account and that sort of stuff but the
part where he was most engaged in the
conversation like locked in bang like
that was when we started talking about
oh I me was one of the people that like
left the left publicly and why I left
the left and I didn't leave liberalism
liberalism left me and he posted a meme
eventually showing how he stayed the
same but it's the left that went bananas
he he fully gets it the same way you get
it he gets it and you can see the way is
being treated by the system I just want
to show you one more clip of the
interview because then uh sorin
basically asked him who he would vote
for and I think this was sort of
interesting I would not vote for Biden
you'd vote for Trump I'm not saying I'd
vote for Trump but I
mean this is this is definitely a
difficult Choice yeah you know would you
would you vote for Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley by the way wants uh all social
media
um names to be exposed do you know no I
think that's outrageous yeah no I'm not
going to vote for some Pro censorship
cand all right I'll do them backwards so
the Nikki Haley one with him um it's
it's like a complete deal breaker right
you're not going to tell a guy who
bought a giant tech company purging
money that they can't have Anonymous
users there are issues with Anonymous
users There's issu issues with trolls
and Bots and all that stuff he's done a
lot with Bots to eliminate Bots by the
way um but it's getting harder and
harder because AI is getting smarter
bots in the old day old days would just
have copy and paste comments and
computers were just you know tweeting
things out repetitively Bots are getting
much smarter they can put your name in
it they can change the language but he
has done more about that but obviously
he's not going to vote for Nikki Haley
like the very idea of that one is just
okay so that one's out of the way uh
then he said uh Trump he's not
sure I my suspicion is he Pro if it ends
up being Biden or Trump and he's brave
enough to say who he will vote for I
think he would vote for Trump but him
being so sort of hands off on on whether
he could support Trump or not I think
shows you the bigger problem with Trump
in general that all of these people who
have so had it with the Democrats there
is still a mass aversion to Trump and
you may not agree with that mass
aversion and you might think it's
misguided or whatever but it is real it
is re all of the people the people that
are waking up right now to all of the
lunacy of the left who previously maybe
even had Trump derangement syndrome and
I'm not accusing El of that they are not
going to vote for Trump there might be
somebody else they would vote for and
I'll get to him in just a second and
then uh first he said that he will not
vote for Biden and I think there's every
reason not to vote for Joe Biden there's
no reason to think that Joe Biden's
actually the president of the United
States he is too old he has dementia
this is really just a a Barack Obama
third term right now and fourth term
upcoming the Middle East is on fire Elon
knows a little something about economics
uh which have very little to do with
biomics you get all that so on
fortunately sorin did not ask about
Ronda santis and I think Elon Musk would
vote for Ronda santis Ronda santis
launched his campaign in a Twitter
spaces with Elon Musk I don't know one
policy that Ronda santis has that uh uh
that Ronda Sanz has that Elon Musk would
not support maybe a maybe the abortion
thing is a little bit much but the
president doesn't have that much to do
with abortion at this point now that
it's been kicked back to the States so I
would have loved to have heard him uh
ask that and I would have loved to have
heard elon's response to that so uh and
I think you know I guess if you want to
just mention VC very quickly I don't
think Elon likes VC actually because BC
thinks that CH climate change is a hoax
and I don't think that's the position of
Elon Musk just relative to what he said
about who's done more for the climate
than
Tesla you know it was making us think
this morning when we were uh prepping
the show it's like can you imagine truly
and I guess I'll do more of this over
the next month and a half till we get to
that first Iowa caucus but can you
imagine if Ronda Santos was President
like if he actually was president and we
had a president who would say what he
was going to do and who was going to do
what he says and he was in office and he
was doing those things and there was no
Sideshow and I know the left would
always they'll always go apoplectic and
they'll figure out ways to go after him
and all that but if the mainstream media
if they just didn't know what to do with
him because it became clear to most
people that we had a good decent honest
man and then we started doing things
right in our country and we started
replicating that Florida thing and then
every morning I would go hello it's
February 6 2024 this is the ruin report
Ronda santis is President I don't have
much to say join us for a postgame show
at Ruben report. locals.com okay ciao
wouldn't that be refreshing I actually
think it's possible we shall see all
right let's get to a locals Community
Q&A uh janzy says hey Dave uh you've
mentioned several times that Israel's
prime minister will have to step down
I'm not sure I understand why I think
he's done done everything that would be
expected for a country to defend itself
I personally think he waited too long to
retaliate well I think ultimately after
this he has to step down now the
question is what does after this mean
because this thing is not going away
Hamas is making it very clear suddenly
they're saying oh they don't even have
all of the hostages maybe Islamic Jihad
has some and some other groups and
they've lost some people they want to
elongate this thing as long as possible
and part of the problem you know Israel
is in a in a unbelievable difficult spot
not just because of the horrific things
that happened to their people and the
hostages but because they they did this
pause right now right we're in this
we're in this temporary ceasefire right
now they're getting their people back
they're getting women and children back
they're not getting men back yet but
they're getting some of their people
back and it's it's allowing the people
there to breathe again right to see some
of their their saved uh citizens and
this is deeply important right and it's
very easy for any of us to say no you
don't you don't negotiate iate it all
you you just keep attacking you but it's
like if that was your sister if that was
your mother you might think a little bit
differently so these are incredibly
difficult things to think about um it's
going to go on for a while they're going
to have to restart like at some point
they'll get a certain amount of people
back and then they'll just say no we
have committed to toppling Hamas and we
are going to do that and by the way it's
what they have to do this is an
existential fight they have a terrorist
group funded by Iran on their borders
that that is just saying even it was
literally right before I started the
show I saw a tweet from the founder of
Hamas basically saying um this was a a
pre-run for the much bigger things that
we plan on doing so you have to destroy
them the issue with
Netanyahu and anyone can argue maybe
they waited a few days too long to
prepare for the ground war I mean they
knew there were all these underground
tunnels and there could be bombs
everywhere and booby traps and and all
of this stuff right the the reason he
has to step down is because at some
point after all of this you have to get
to some kind of national healing the guy
has been on andof prime minister for for
over 20 years he's done an unbelievable
job and it's it's it's very sad for I
would say the country and for his legacy
that what people will mostly remember
him or is the failure here the security
failure here on the 7th and they'll
they'll figure all of that out they have
incredible technology they'll figure out
exactly what happened and all of that
stuff but I think what the only way the
country will be able to heal is he will
have to say this thing did happen under
my watch thus it is my fault at the end
of the day um and then I got you through
it right we're still here it was painful
we're still here however that long that
took but now I have to step aside I and
I think he'll do it because I think he
loves his nation that much and I think
he would do it without without a lot of
fanfare or anything else you know
interestingly I watched um on the way
back from London I watched the movie
goldo which is about goldo Mayer Who was
the the prime minister of Israel during
the OM Kipper war in 1973 it was a
little difficult to watch actually
because in light of everything that's
going on but I I I wanted to watch it
and um it basically is taking place as
post the war so they've won the war but
they got very close to losing the war
and she's being questioned by all of the
authorities on what her role in almost
losing the war was and they why didn't
they do anything earlier you know and
she basically says something to the
effect of you know when you leave this
job you pretty you're pretty much a
failure like if you leave the job as in
this case prime minister or president in
in a place that it is so difficult to
survive like something horrible is going
to happen on your watch and your best
hope is that it's a little bit better uh
when you got out than when you got in
and that that's the tough part for
Netanyahu right now uh Rachel says when
did you start growing your beard at
mustache and would you be willing to
throw back to a pick without them so I
started this beard it was I believe in
August of 2017 when I went off the grid
I just was like I'm just not going to
shave for a month I think we do have a
picture from right before that so that's
me right before that now I do have to
note you know I'm a little I've lost
some weight but I'm a little like
bloated in the face there and puffy uh I
was on some of you remember this I was
on this crazy I didn't I didn't talk
about it at the time but I was on this
crazy experimental medication because I
had developed alopecia Arata about a
year before that it's an autoimmune
disease they don't know why it comes it
was a horrible horrible time I was
losing huge chunks of hair mostly in the
back of my head but on the top too it
was really horrible and I went on this
experimental medication that basic the
idea of it was you would put something
almost like poison ivy that's the way it
was described to me they put that on
your head with the hope that your white
blood cells will then attack that the
reaction that you're having instead of
attacking your hair follicles so your
hair will grow back because your white
blood cells will then attack anyway it
it was unbel put that picture back up
like it was not it was not a great time
for me but the promo shot was okay the
lighting was nice and everything else um
but anyway I I just I like the beard I
think it gives my face a little uh
definition and as I often say I'm more
beard than man now so the beard the
beard ain't going anywhere but those are
the old days anyway let me get to one ad
guys and then we'll continue with
questions uh are you tired of being
targeted with fishing emails fed up with
Spam cluttering your inbox concerned
about companies like Google or the
government spying on your private
conversations then it's time to start
switching to start mail startmail is a
secure alternative to Gmail that lets
you send emails like they're in sealed
envelopes making sure your communication
stays private and secure secure uh
services like Google collect your data
and use it for targeted ads start mail
is strictly an ADF free service that
does not collect nor share any data with
third parties for advertisement or
tracking your startmail account comes
with all the features you need including
unlimited disposable email addresses to
protect your inbox from fishing scams
and hacking attempts switching to start
mail is super easy if you're worried
about your old email stored in Gmail
Outlook Yahoo and all the rest they've
got you covered they hassle-free
migration tool lets you move your emails
and contacts with just a couple clicks
no technical knowledge required over the
past decade startmail has become a
trusted name in email privacy so why
wait any longer switch to startmail and
experience the peace of mind that comes
with the truly secure email service sign
up today and save 50% on your first year
subscription go to startmail.com dve and
join millions of people who are moving
away from Big Tech to secure email
providers that start mail with a t
dve and now back to me okay next
question Larry says we have established
that the corporate media have been lying
to us about several issues and events
what else are they lying to us
about what do I always say it's like I'm
not worried about the stuff they're
lying to us about and like the
algorithms and all of the tricks like
I'm always worried about the things that
we don't know about like what are the
algorithm I'm not worried about Shadow
Banning per se I'm worried about all of
the other stuff the mainstream media
they lie like again I referenced it
earlier but the New York York Times the
the gall of sorcin there to pretend that
while he sits with the New York Times
logo behind him pretending that X is
somehow a dangerous company and that
Elon Musk is somehow a bigot knowing all
of the evil stuff that the New York
Times has done just in the last couple
weeks right with the alifa hospital
pretending they bombed it and then they
had to change their headline three times
and it turned out it was actually bombed
by Hamas and it also turned out that the
picture the New York Times used on the
front page wasn't even the hospital like
that he would have the gall to sit there
and and and pretend that Elon Musk is
the bad guy but I there is no end to the
uh the bottomless hole that that is
these people and what leftism has become
um I don't know what else are they lying
to us about honestly it could be
everything at this I have no freaking
idea but all you can do is try to find
sane people and incorporate them into
your life and piler some goodness out of
your existence here and and build
something decent whether whether that's
a family or a business or a home or
whatever and and try to make some sense
of it that's really the best you can do
uh Cheryl says are you planning to do
eight nights of Hanukkah gifts for the
boys or how will you begin we have five
grandsons and my husband has zero
restraint got any suggestions for
managing that man you got five grandsons
uh eight Knights that's 40 gifts for
grandchildren that is a lot of gifts um
you know the thing is we are very very
blessed we have the things that we want
I I we don't want more toys here so my
mom uh called me earlier in the week and
she said what can we get the boys for
Hanukkah and I was like we don't really
want anything I was like I don't know
maybe a wooden car uh I don't like my
major thing and these guys can testify
to it in my house I cannot have
electronic beeping toys we have one bus
there is one bus that they can press it
sings the alphabet a a and b n c it does
it in a weird way like that d e f
g I can't stand that freaking thing I
like wood toys I like you know you could
I like musical things that kind of stuff
is just fine I can't have electronic
beeping and worrying and all the rest of
it um so they you know for any of you
that have kids or if you had young kids
they don't even want the toys you open
up a toy they want to play with the box
like we have a drawer in the kitchen on
the bottom that they're allowed to open
up and I have like I have like Ice Cube
uh holders ice cube makers in there like
rubber Ice Cube makers and we've got
like some measuring cups they like that
stuff so I no there will not be eight
nights of toys we will light the candles
every night and I think they'll enjoy
that but uh no that is no please nobody
don't send us any more gifts thank you
thank you Tamara says uh is there any
hope for people who cannot leave
California well look California is
absolutely massive there are millions
and millions of good people there
obviously right I think they say that
California has more Republicans than any
other state if I'm not mistaken because
of the giant amount of population it's
just hard to believe
look if you live in a big city in Cali
if you live in Los Angeles San Francisco
even San Jose is a dump Santa Monica is
a dump um San Diego is starting to have
problems which is one of the most
beautiful cities in the United States
but they're just dumping all of the the
illegal immigrants there um if you live
in one of the big cities it's going to
be tough we we have friends that live
like an hour outside of Sonoma that are
basically Off the Grid and they're doing
fine they smoke pot all day they don't
know what's going on but I don't think
BLM is going to show up at their door um
I don't know what you do if you live in
if you're in Cali for whatever reason
you know we had a caller on people of
the internet yesterday who still living
in Cali and he was basically like look
my parents are here and you know a
certain amount of people you know it's
like if you have elderly parents that
have lived their whole life in one place
they might be in a home like the idea of
moving them you could have other you
some child with a medical issue you
could everyone has their own
circumstances why they can or can't do
things you you have Financial
considerations it's not easy to just up
and move as badly as I wanted to get out
of Cy it's not we had just moved into
that house a year before I thought we
were going to live in that house and
raise our kids in that house and I
thought we were going to live there
forever I did not want to leave that
house um I love that house the guy who
built that house actually I'm trying to
get him to come to to Miami to start
building houses here because he's
selling houses in LA and he can't sell
them anymore he's the most beautiful uh
house home builder I've ever seen um
everyone has their own considerations I
would say if you can get out I mean put
aside everything else put aside the
burning cities the drugs
all of the stuff you are paying another
10% roughly of your income to the
government of California that we don't
pay here in Florida and yet everything
still works here what does that tell you
it tells you it's a giant grift our
roads are better here our our schools
are better here a new study came out
yesterday Florida has the number one
public schools in the country
like but but I get it everyone has their
own considerations LW says how do you
think Democrats are going to cheat in
the upcoming elections next year with
computer glitches being recently exposed
look who the hell knows computer
glitches ballot harvesting everything
else the only way we fix this Dave
you're going to talk about Florida yes
is you do what Florida is we we did we
had a complete uh evaluation
re-evaluation of our election security
if you had missed my interview with
Florida Secretary of State cord bird
which was about was great name cord bird
uh from about six months ago he talks
about what they did when he became
Secretary of State to ensure that our
elections would be clean and clear and
you show an ID and paper ballot and I've
talked about it you you there's just
they're checking you all the way through
there's just no saying person in America
that is questioning the validity of our
elections that's what we have to export
but it's like who knows what's going to
happen on Election night a year you know
it's a year almost a year no it's 11
months and or so from now it's like who
knows what's going to happen that night
another pipe has burst in Philly another
this that the other thing and we'll just
do it all over again and and then over
time the more you do all these weird
things the less people that believe in
the system and when people stop
believing in the system the system kind
of stops working that's Padme
amadala in Attack of the Clones uh Amy
Says is there a Christmas movie that you
do not like that almost everyone else
seems to love so I was going through the
questions normally I don't glance
through the questions we had a few extra
minutes this morning I glance through
the questions and I and I there is a a
Christmas movie that I don't love I just
don't love it I don't find it that funny
I don't find it that amusing and and
whatever and and I'm getting a lot of
crap from Phoenix over here but I don't
think elf is that great of a movie I
just I don't care for will uh
Barrell even I don't even love anchor
man it's better yeah I just it's not
really it's not Fenix said we're
breaking up he's handing in his
resignation right now goodbye no anchor
man's actually pretty decent but it's
like not fully my thing but but elf I
just don't love it but in light of
Christmas season and everything else I
thought I could tell you my Fe three
favorite Christmas movies by far
Christmas Vacation Chevy Chase like that
is primo Christmas Christmas movie I
just love Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas kiss my ass
kiss his ass happy hanuka it's just a
great great it's like Peak Chevy Chase
it's so great that scene right there
when he's chopping down the tree after
their tree uh breaks through the window
and uh what's her name from Seinfeld
Julia Lou drus lives now it's just great
great great Christmas Story which they
we basically put that on David's family
had a tradition uh of just watching
Christmas Story over and over and over
again I think back in the day TNT used
to do 24 hours of Christmas story so we
do that every year and put it back up
one more time because people are
wondering Die Hard is a Christmas movie
it takes place on Christmas day or was
it a Christmas Eve uh there's Christmas
decorations they're at a Christmas party
at nakatomi Tower it is a Christmas
movie and it is a great great great
great movie movie I will try to watch
Elf one more time you know what we will
watch Elf together and see what happens
we will see what happens Steve says
having met Elon before what do you think
of him on a personal and human level is
he a nice guy well I think I talked
about it a bit up top obviously I mean
what you're seeing out of him up there
when he's thoughtful and thinking and as
I said it's almost like you can kind of
see his brain is working faster than the
stuff is coming out of his mouth so he
stammers a bit when he's talking that's
exactly what you get the one thing that
you're not fully seeing with him that I
was really surprised by especially the
first time is he's funny like he's
actually funny like he's like he likes
talking you know a couple times he
showed me like funny memes that were on
his phone or whatever and he and he
laughs a lot he's a very hardy hardy
laugh um but what I was more impressed
with than anything else in the two times
that we met is that he was extremely
generous of time the first time that I
met him I got the call it was like 2
p.m. here east coast and I get the call
can you meet with on today and I was
like scrambling how can I get there and
I ended up I jumped on a flight I get
there at about 900 p.m. he's in meetings
they were like all right you'll probably
have to meet him tomorrow but hang
around in the area just in case because
he does take meetings basically all
night long so I'm hanging out in the
area by there and you all know what's
going on in San Francisco it doesn't
feel very safe and everything else but I
was with a friend and then I get the
call okay he can see you now it was it
was 12:30 a.m. and he's still taking
meetings uh I go into to the office and
uh we chat briefly for a second oh
you're in Florida now and okay blah blah
blah and then he's like he's like uh
he's like listen if if the problems that
you're having with your Twitter account
are really really severe we could deal
with this right now he's like otherwise
I've had a and he his eyes were kind of
bloodshot it was clear he was tired he's
like but if the problems you're having a
really really severe we we'll take care
of this right now he's like otherwise
would you mind if we took care of this
tomorrow and I was like think how
absolutely insane that is I'm one random
guy on Twitter okay okay like here's the
world's richest man basically at 1:00
a.m. after a long ass day this is just
you know basically a couple weeks after
he got Twitter with all of the other
things he's trying to send people to
Mars and he's like yes I'll stay awake
to to needle around and Fiddle around
with your Twitter account to figure out
what's going on they're like how much
more can I say about the guy than that
so there you go uh guys let's talk about
gravity to Fire Shoes then we'll get to
the next questions I want to tell you
about something that's been making my
days a whole lot easier gravity to Fire
Shoes these shoes are something else as
you know I am a fan of comfortable
Footwear but these shoes take it to a
whole new level more than just shoes
they're basically clouds for your feet
in a double blind study by Olive View
UCLA Medical Center and published in the
Journal of the American podiatric
Medical Association participants
experienced 85% less knee pain its most
powerful shock absorption system ever
put into a shoe gravity def fire has
patented Verso shck technology it's like
a midi trampoline in your shoes whether
you're strolling through the park
running
or even just lounging at home these
shoes have got your back or I should say
your feet even better they're stylish
you get both comfort and style that
looks good and feels great so here's the
deal gravity def fire is offering a
limited exclusive holiday deal just for
you guys go to GD fy. comom gdf y.com
use promo code ruben3 at checkout to get
an extra 30% off your order that's an
amazing 30% off for being here today
it's a holiday thank you gift from
Gravity to fire why not treat your feet
to some welld deserved Comfort that's
gdf y.com promo code ruben3 to give your
feet the love they need and now back to
me
Chris says what's your favorite beef
dish chicken dish fish dish and pork
dish all right beef dish well my
favorite like especially if we're having
people over there is nothing better than
just getting like the big Tomahawk I do
it for these guys all the time like if
you and if you can get wagu it is not
cheap um but just like the big tomok it
just looks awesome and you slice it and
then everybody can get a little portion
that's still left on the bone but I'll
tell you if you if you don't want to do
something that expensive you can get a
nice skirt steak get get a nice try to
get Prime Cut if you can which is a
little bit more obviously than Choice
Cut but skirt steak you cannot screw it
up skirt steak it's thin it's pretty
tender usually little salt and pepper
you don't need much more and do like
five minutes on both sides on the grill
at about 400 450 you that's what we had
last night you cannot screw it up and
it's juicy and tender and good chicken
dis oh oh chicken parm David makes an
incredible chicken parm you can go to
David's cookbook. comom to get the uh to
get the ingredients and the the recipe
on that one it is he makes the most
delicious chicken parm Megan Kelly of
the internet said that it is the best
chicken parm she's ever had fish dish um
I do a lot of simple salmon I just throw
the salmon in a cast iron cook it at 400
for 20 minutes but fish dish David he
doesn't do it that often now cuz with
the kids it's tough but he'll take a
whole brand Zino filet it you can
lightly Grill it with some herbs you get
some thyme and some Rosemary and a
couple other things dice it up really
nice and uh and you just put it on the
grill and it's just little lemon just
perfect pork dish you know I'm not a
huge I'm not a huge pork guy I I like
bacon but I'm not I'm not like I don't
go out Conor loves the
pork Conor loves pork tacos so let's
just say pork tacos Conor loves the
pork
Samantha says have you ever visited
Portugal and would you ever consider
organizing an event in lisman Jordan
Peterson's show was a huge hit that he
came out for a second round I have never
been to Portugal I absolutely would
Phoenix can you get us to Portugal all
right Phoenix we'll make it happen we're
going to go to Portugal I would love to
go I think that portion of Jordan's tour
was was post our portion we we didn't do
much in that part of Europe but uh that
would be that would be absolutely
fantastic we didn't do it that much all
over the world in C certain spots so uh
Randy says who is the one person that
you would love to be able to interview
living or dead well I'd say preferably
living would be better um who well I've
answered this one a bunch of times I
really I just it's corny I suppose at
some level I just want to interview
George Lucas the creator of Star Wars I
think his story not just because of the
why I love the lore of Star Wars and and
the heroes journey and just he did cool
things you know one thing that he likes
talking about I've heard you know
because people ask him all the things
about Star Wars he gets tired of talking
about it but one very cool thing he did
in Star Wars is pre- Star Wars every
Future movie that there was every sci-fi
movie anything that took place in the
future it was all very clean right 2001
the future was very clean it was very
white and it was very sort of doile and
controlled but in Star Wars what you see
are the jaas and the broken down droids
and because even in the future things
will break down things will be dirty and
gritty and everything like it's just an
interesting thing to think about but
just that he created so much lore that
captured my imagination and it captured
the imagination possibly of billions of
people on planet Earth I just think
would be great and and the other part
that I'd love to talk about he was
fighting the studios the entire time
they were cutting his budgets he
ultimately took the the ability to
monetize the toys the action figures
which nobody thought boys would be
playing with action figures it was
always girls played with dolls nobody
really thought that boys would play with
dolls that he you know they eventually
called them action figures and then that
became in some ways bigger than the
movies altogether but he had the force
it on that so yeah Ashley says how do I
deal with my liberal Jewish in-laws this
holiday season the topic of the Israel
war has come up a few times and it's so
mindblowing how they can't see the
people they vote for have helped
facilitate this War I get so frustrated
and I just have to walk away so how can
I effectively communicate with these
people look this is tough unfortunately
what has happened to so many
people um regard Jewish Christian
whatever atheists doesn't matter is that
leftism and liberalism has become the
belief set so in this case and
unfortunately this happened to a lot of
liberal Jews in the United States I
think there's a lot of reasons for it
some of the reasons are post Holocaust
reasons meaning that people came here
and they put assimilation above
everything else so you had to sort of
put aside all of the old traditions and
old things because oh people thought oh
my god look what happened to us in
Europe let's forget all of that but then
the thing is you end up believing in new
things so you end up believing in
secular institutions and all of these
things and then when these things start
failing
you it's like this real no pun intended
come to Jesus moment you either will
realize what has happened and maybe
should turn back to some of that old
stuff or you end up in this odd thing
where you're voting for the very same
people who would gladly behead you and
everything else um I have a lot more to
say on that and we should probably do
some other shows on that but
um the best thing you can do is just try
to calmly talk to them and explain some
of these issues um I know it sucks we've
all got these issues in our families
trust me I have them as well um I can
say it's been nice over the last couple
months like getting some calls and texts
from people where nobody really
apologizes for not talking to you for a
long time or saying bad things about you
or unfollowing you but they kind of
might be like oh I shared that thing of
you or maybe you weren't a complete
lunatic or maybe when the New York Times
said you were the leader of the
alt-right they weren't correct you know
that sort of thing but well look the New
York Times is an example of that if you
if you put aside all of your old beliefs
and then you just believe in liberalism
in secularism the New York Times became
like the new Bible to people so there's
a certain set of people if you're
talking about your your liberal Jewish
Family they probably still subscribe to
the New York Times They probably still
watch MSNBC or CNN they they've been
they just replace one set of beliefs for
another set of beliefs and getting
people out of that is really really
tricky um maybe watch this you know
watch this show and over time they might
realize that I'm not a complete
psychotic lunatic and maybe that paves
the way but I wish you luck I wish any
everybody luck regardless of the
holidays you're going to be celebrating
the religion or no religion or anything
else like getting together with family
and being able to do that it has gotten
very very tricky it's one of the most it
might be the most nefarious thing that
the woke did because in the old days
everyone could do it my family was unbel
I wrote about it actually in in don't
burn this book that my family was
incredibly good about that every holiday
that my family had didn't matter if it
was Thanksgiving or Passover anything we
could do it we would argue about
everything and I I'm the oldest of my
generation so I was always trying to get
from the Kids Table to the adult table
so I could be involved in those
conversations and they would argue arue
everybody and it was getting heated and
then my mom or my aunt or my grandma
would be like all right desserts here
and then everyone would just stop and
that was it and we were good and we do
it again the next night and that's what
we have to get back to Elizabeth says
what's the best dad joke you've got well
you
know the thing about having kids is
there's there's all this pooping and
crying and peeing in the house and all
and it's just it's just endless and then
you bring kids into it so it's it's an
awful lot there you
see you didn't have any crickets
or
um I'll give you I'll give you another
one uh about it's well this one's about
kids and I don't remember the comedian
who used to tell this joke but there was
a comedian when I was doing standup way
back in the day who used to do this joke
it was something like uh you know I'm at
the supermarket I'm in the uh the melon
section there the fruit section and
there's this woman hitting her kid she's
just hitting her kid and we're we're all
looking like oh my God this woman's
hitting her kid what what are we going
to do you know it's like what what do
you do just beating your kid oh my God
what are you going to do I was going to
do something but what right do I have to
hit this
kid working hard over here working hard
uh Steve says Dave will we ever see a
don't burn this food cookbook of your
favorite recipes I'm sure it will be a
hit yes we are working on it it's mostly
going to be David's recipes we have been
trying to do this for a long time you
know having kids uh it distracts you
from an awful lot of other things and he
I'm doing most of the cooking around
here even though he's an incredible chef
uh because he's he's doing most of the
stuff with the kids but yes we are
working with that I've also started I
know a lot of you have asked um don't
burn this book don't burn this country
and I think you can probably figure out
what the third name will be it will be a
Trilogy I've started sketching out the
ideas on that one so I'm working on that
one too but uh stay tuned on all of that
we have a postgame show coming up in
about 30 seconds at Ruben report.
locals.com uh my full interview it's an
abbreviated interview but full interview
with Brian Griffin who's Ronda Sis's
press secretary is up right now and the
big debate is tonight the
Nome
uh Nome even saying his name you feel
you get that the Newsome D sanis debate
is on Fox tonight with Sean Hannity
obviously will be covering that tomorrow
postgame show and just a sec and we
leave you with Elon
[Music]
Musk